bonjour nous sommes en septembre les
feuilles tombées pour certains d'entre
vous que vous serez refoulés lève c'est
la rentrée quelle motivation c'est pour
coller à ce thème que j'ai décidé de
faire une vidéo sur l'histoire de
l'histoire
eh ouais ou plutôt sur l'histoire de
l'enseignement de l'histoire si vous
êtes salir jours à l'école primaire vous
vous souvenez peut-être les grandes
dates et personnages qu'on vous a
martelé charlemagne 800 clovis le vase
de 75 115 marignan en 50 avant
jésus-christ toute la gaule est occupée
et saufs
alors pourquoi ces dates pourquoi ces
personnages qui nous a imposé cette
vision de l'histoire alors qu'on aurait
pu apprendre à analyser des trous de
poteaux celle enquête que nous allons
mener dans cet épisode
sous l'ancien régime c'est à dire avant
la révolution française on enseigne
surtout l'histoire sainte à partir de
l'ancien et du nouveau testament et à la
fin du xviiie siècle c'est à dire avant
que la révolution ne bouscule tout on
commence par l'histoire sainte dans les
premières classes qui explique l'origine
de l'humanité pour l'époque oui et là tu
vas dire un truc comme et on a bien
évolué depuis
pas du tout tu trouveras encore quelques
écoles américaines où on enseigne le
créationnisme au lieu de l'évolution
l'histoire au xviiie siècle continue
avec l'enseignement de l'antiquité pour
finir avec l'histoire de france un
changement radical se produit à partir
des années 1870 avec la défaite de la
france contre la prusse puisqu'on
considère que les français se sont fait
écraser parce qu'ils étaient moins
patriote que les prussiens
on cherche aussi à ancrer la troisième
république qui vient tout juste de
succéder au second empire à propos savez
vous pourquoi on parle de second empire
et pas de deuxième empire ou de seconde
guerre mondiale et pas de deuxième
guerre mondiale
c'est parce qu'il n'y en a pas eu de
troisième s'il y avait eu un troisième
empire on parlerait de deuxième empire
tout comme on parle de deuxième
république
merci mr pas mal me piquent pas mon
boulot quand même bref le meilleur moyen
de transmettre l'amour de la nation aux
plus jeunes c'est bien sûr en leur
montrant à quel point leur pays a une
histoire grandiose
on oublie l'histoire de la création
abandonné à partir de 1865
on laisse un peu de côté l'antiquité et
on s'intéresse à l'histoire de france à
partir de personnages emblématiques qui
illustreront la grandeur de la nation
comme moi non comme nos ancêtres les
gaulois un peu plus guerrier efforts
représenter de manière très caricatural
dans les manuels de la troisième
république
tous les gaulois porte forcément un
casque débrayé une moustache et passent
leur temps à se taper dessus
à les lire on croirait des cendres des
d'autres acquis d'autant que nous
descendons tout aussi bien des francs
des romains et de tout un mélange de
peuples on préfère également se
concentrer sur la vie de certains
personnages plutôt que sur une histoire
globale qui montrerait la manière
revivez les populations l'étude de
clovis notamment son baptême permet de
montrer l'unité chrétienne de la nation
de même on apprend aux élèves la
victoire de charles martel contre les
arabes à poitiers en 732 afin de mettre
en valeur la capacité du pays à
repousser les envahisseurs poitiers
n'est pas la seule bataille entre les
français des arabes à cette période il
ne s'agissait pas de repousser une
invasion mais plutôt une petite
incursion à tel point que les chroniques
arabe mentionne très peu cet événement
13 juillet 732 haddad rahman n'est
toujours pas rentré de la cueillette aux
champignons
je pense qu'il est mort peut-être que
j'avais honte d'avoir perdu
peut-être mais de notre côté ça va faire
mille trois cents ans qu'on se vante
d'avoir gagné ne vous mettez donc pas
trop martel en tête les professeurs
d'histoire à bord d'autres personnages
emblématiques comme saint louis louis
xiv est évidemment jeanne d'arc jeanne
d'arc est une femme qui entendait la
voix de dieu qui a sommé mois de france
qui a renvoyé les anglais chez eux et
qui s'est sacrifié pour son pays c'est
du pain béni quoique un peu trop cuit je
ne vais pas revenir sur son parcours
mais elles représentent toutes les idées
que l'état sous la troisième république
veut transmettre aux jeunes générations
et c'est pourquoi elle a été autant
étudier en un mot comme en cent
l'histoire enseignée aux élèves et au
service de la nation et chaque partie du
programme sert à transmettre des valeurs
en plus des connaissances
ernest lavisse qui écrit le manuel
scolaire le plus utilisé entre 1884 et
1950 parle d'une histoire qui s'apprend
par le coeur et c'est beau de même la
géographie permet de montrer la beauté
du pays dans lequel nous vivons et
l'instruction morale et civique permet
d'en rajouter une petite couche au cas
où les enfants n'auraient pas bien
compris les français sont forts la
france est un beau pays
vous êtes français ce n'est qu'après la
seconde guerre mondiale que les choses
évoluent l'histoire géographie éducation
civique prend une nouvelle tournure et a
pour vocation de lutter contre le
racisme et l'intolérance afin de ne pas
reproduire les erreurs qui ont été
commises pendant la guerre
on veut donc enseigner une histoire
universelle on ne voit les programmes à
d'autres civilisations d'europe et de
même des autres continents et c'est ce
vers quoi entend aujourd'hui il ya eu de
nombreuses manières d'écrire l'histoire
et la plupart des historiens essaye de
rester le plus objectif possible mais il
est difficile de rester totalement
objectif quand on travaille sur une
source qui peut être incomplète mal
interprété etc
j'espère que cette nouvelle vidéo vous
intéresser si vous êtes collégiens ou
lycéens je suis sûr que vous avez
maintenant à tenir
manuel d'histoire pour voir de quoi
parler le programme et si vous en avez
fini avec tout ça vous pouvez toujours
vous replonger dans vos vieux cahiers
qui vous ne vous en espace et en vue
pour refus elle que j'adore ta quad
écrit sur mon époque
spoiler il assez d'avoir regardé bonne
rentrée pour certains il a bien fait